Chương ngày mai hai tháng 15, căn thẳng biên giới gợp các buồn chia và thái lan buồn phát,
sau khi sảy ra vụ nổ xuống tại tình bán trẻ mình chai khiến những năng dân thường các buồn chia bị thương.
Theo một trường thương tiên các buồn chia nét phát ra,
côn đổi thái lan đã nổ xuống chương sáng lãnh thổ các buồn chia,
bá lúc khoảng 10 xấu dật, tại khu vực làng Great Jan, Vietnam Ultra,
tình chừng bán tế mình chai ở ngoại ông Ratei,
gọi đây là hàng đồng gơi căn thẳng biên chào,
đây giữa an ninh và sinh mạng người dân vụ biên.
Chính quyền địa phương đã đưa những người bị thương đi cấp tử và yêu cầu nhiều trà làm sõ vụ việc.
Fiat pháp buồn chia cũng đang khẩn chương trình thái bị pháp ngoại giao,
nhằm kiểm soát anh hình, đồng thời tiêu hỏi suy chiếm thủy để tránh lao thông suốt.
Fiat làng trưng bảo cũng vơi yêu cầu các buồn chia có lời xin lỗi chính thức,
sau khi một vụ nổ miên giọc biên giới khiến bóng đình sĩ thái lan bị thương.
Giờ đình biển bán cấp đình chỉ vô thời ạng việc thực hiện phỏa thuận lương bán vừa đặt được gần đây.
Thái lan cũng được ra khá bộ trước rằng các buồn chia đã cải miếm mới, giọc biển giới với cuối xa này.